welcome to this video playing Jurgis
Yahoo's from Slovakia I don't know I
never played it before nope so just go
for normal clothes through it and with
d3 ok yeah played this quite a bit
nights not coming to e3 that off him but
certainly been playable Wow be three hmm
it looks strange ok may put this on f6
make it more difficult for him to play
d4 and yet now you're not going to play
the form
yeah give both his bishops look a bit
strange okay so okay let's go away five
could have taken on c3 as well but oh
that sets good news I don't have a week
a pawn now you the other than that
position I like very much I've got a
very good structure yeah and this I'm
sorry to relocate here at the desk it's
taking that f6 bishop as well no
threatening Bishop reform so aged three
looks like the only move or maybe you
can move the night but I mean he
certainly cannot allow me to play Bishop
g4 and just kill a spawn structure so he
wants to move the night on I don't go
and get it 25 or what is the point hmm I
can still take f3 it's an interesting
interesting idea playing with the two
nights against the two bishops but i can
also i can also just take care right go
age six maybe or f6
f 6h 30 yeah let's do that oh it's
really allowing that that's cool check
talk about a funky bishop on be one so
it's F for an issue that i need to stop
or not i can also go just d5 hmm wonder
about it I think I should go 85 make
sure that f4 is really never ever
happening
yeah d 524 is an option I can just
regroup the night to e6 yeah that's good
now not to 86 that should that should be
the end of it actually I don't see how
is ever going to get out of this
so where he might come up with the king
so age five yeah there's really no
reason not to play age five
gather bishop I'm be one that's the
proud we bishop in yeah and one of his
yeah less proud moments so it doesn't
matter really I think Jesus have no f7 I
mean probably doesn't matter 94 was
already possible but he cannot prevent
it
okay so nice 24 we should be one and we
are coming close to some kind of zoosk
lon there's something even better maybe
90 phone back in the f5 maybe
okay I don't know that position is so
nice check
yeah I just go for King edge 696 and
then bring the h-bond up check
check 94 again so f5 or not certainly
playable and let's do it
timeline and I cannot get some kind of
complete zoosk long here it would be
nice and doesn't look like it strangely
enough
yeah one of those pawns ultimately whip
the fall check check hmm I really didn't
play that well check check and
20-something seconds watch HAC I just I
just was some relishing this great
position too much and forgot to really
win it ah come on don't give me this one
and it's rather unbelievable him I don't
believe it oh I'm the stupid idiot ever
that was the worst position ever really
that he had unbelievable I just I can't
believe it forfeits on time
oh my god that's the worst defeat in
ages okay yeah this is out of a textbook
out and not play chess and white is
completely lost and I just was shuffling
around here forever in this winning
position everything winds everything
winds and probably everything does win I
mean probably I should just win the porn
like 94 or something but I just I just I
was just um yeah as I said relishing
this too much Jack Jack Oh probably I
could have taken some material or what I
don't know I don't get it really can
what did happen here I mean okay King
Air Force One one way to win now just
win all the porns but I just thought
okay I can do I can do everything this
is a prom a somewhat bad idea I mean
it's hard to screw up completely gay
played this this strange move check and
no I'm sort of screwing this up check it
still should be winning but by now I got
irritated of course be mean the position
before was just like completely dead
for liking the foster wind check check
still the wind according to the engine d
5 where porn is quicker never know I was
completely understand that he actually
reached this position up until now we're
talking about a draw I guess no but I
came and that wasn't a great idea
putting the night there and somewhere
around here I lose it hey I just I just
tossed that porn something like this I
it's to the draw but ah this is this is
unforgivable this was the worst position
ever with its good at bishop oh my god
check yeah I mean okay it's always a bit
difficult to to analyze this kind of
thing because every move does win but
what is the easiest actually maybe if I
now think of it maybe I should do this
like this move and this is actually very
easier this is a suit swung right after
doing this what I'm talking about is
what i can do is which is very simple
this and he moves whatever and i go here
and then I will take you with the night
oh yes you take and give me this and now
I just play Knight f4 and run over with
a king here like this this is the
simplest thing I hear you don't even
need to calculate a single line check
yeah I was just thinking everything
winds okay which which is true in fact
but you still have to do it okay now
you're King f4 is a pretty simple way to
to do it just winds all the pawns Wow ah
yeah this is n no session after this
game I cannot continue to play thanks
for watching